the restaurant industry is being
challenged unlike others you know
there's many states were tipped
employees get paid about 220 an hour and
it's an employee tip credit of you know
whatever it is $13 an hour to adjust
their payroll down so these employees
typically make twenty thirty forty
dollars an hour in tips in many of these
places so they make to 20 now and
payroll from 220 an hour to $15 is a 600
percent payroll increase there is no
business in the world that can sustain a
600 percent payroll increase so I'm
trying to protect my industry I'm trying
to protect the people that work in the
industry by creating a stable economic
model so there is no guilt instability
[Music]
how worried are you that small
businesses the guy that just wants to
make a great bar a great restaurant not
not a franchise not a big business but
the guy that wants in his hometown to
just put the greatest restaurant ever
there that they will have looked at what
happened over the last year and be like
you know what the risks risks always I'm
sure you know the numbers for
restaurants and bars if you want to tell
everybody the the failure rates they're
always absurdly high but now the risks
seem almost incalculably high for people
to want to get in on this you know it's
interesting that you mentioned I own a
franchise called taffer's tavern and we
created this franchise you'll find us
interesting and I'm not doing this as a
plug we two years ago had no labor pool
we were approaching $15 minimum wages
and a labor pool that we did have were
mostly new Americans who didn't speak
English so well so I said I got to
create the casual dining concept of the
future so I want to cut labor costs in
half I want to bring in robotic cooking
robotic ovens eliminate
back-of-the-house create this whole new
restaurant model so I did I worked with
companies like middle B and worked in
test kitchens around the country and
created this kitchen of the future
concept a year ago created called
Packers Tavern did our franchisee
registration started to franchise kovat
happens we find out we don't have any
raw protein in our restaurant it's all
sous-vide cooking
everything is individually wrapped
prepared and computerized ovens it's
really high quality so we don't have raw
and cooked product we don't have grease
we don't even have hoods so we have a
very different cooking model it is the
kitchen of the future we are the most
covent safe kitchen in the world we
didn't even design it this way so now we
put uniforms on our kitchen staff we
have cameras in the kitchen so you can
see your food be prepared right on your
phone and we created the safest cleanest
kitchen concept in the country starting
on a whole different basis so I launched
my franchises and I'm answering your
question for you because this is
interesting they haven't we sold a bunch
of franchises we sold Washington we sold
the lanta a whole bunch of territories
we're doing very very well the franchise
is going covet hits shoot sales stop of
franchises about 45 days later we get a
phone call from some people that say
listen we're a franchise company we were
interested in buying your franchise and
here's why we want to buy it now because
we think some of the greatest restaurant
locations in America are going to become
available in the next 90 days and we
want to jump on those locations with a
concept that has good solid economic
modeling and you know it's an
interesting I never quite thought that
way so we just sold the city of Boston
we just sold the city of Washington DC
to sophisticated developers who are now
dropping them in places like Fanueil
Hall because these locations have become
available my point is this there's
opportunity now and the industry is
going to go through a shift there's no
question about it
but there's great locations that are
going to be available now there's
aggressive landlords so we'll give you a
very aggressive deals right now with 10
and allowing packages and free rent for
a year or two I mean they will bend over
backwards to do those deals so to that
fictitious restaurant guy that we were
just talking about who's scared to do it
maybe this is the time to do it and I
put a fascinating thought model out
there now we have a big to go element
that we've put in in taffer's tavern and
a curbside element so we shifted the
business model
post Colvin obviously Dave but my point
is this if you've ever wanted to be in a
restaurant business one of the highest
costs we got is occupancy and
construction today there's unbelievable
opportunity
they're don't just think the cogut is
bad for the industry it could be good
for the industry too for some people in
the end the interesting
yeah well chaos always brings
opportunity I'm actually glad you
brought up the automated kitchen and
mentioned a little bit about the
economics of some of this because it is
something that I talk about a lot on the
show relative to minimum wage and the
rest of it so for you as a guy that want
I know you want to employ people you
want people to feel empowered and feel
like they have some control in their
lives and all that when you're making
those decisions to go well wait a minute
I can't pay these people $15 an hour
because technically they're not worth it
if they don't speak the language and all
that without getting into all the
specifics of that do you have sort of
like almost like a philosophical
struggle there between how to go ahead
and do a new business that isn't gonna
hire as many people potentially but is
going to be more of say a restaurant of
the future and something that's
sustainable that's that's your whole
point honestly no and of course there's
a personal fact you want to hire as many
people as you can you know my proudest
day is when I had about 900 employees
and I used to say think to myself every
night I put about a thousand meals on a
table every day I was really proud of
that but you know today my
responsibility to sustain the jobs of
the people that work for me to provide
them with an opportunity that is
consistent is gonna last and provide
them with a good income bigger doesn't
necessarily mean more stable doesn't
mean more income for everyone also
there's what about the guy who built all
the robotics who programmed all the
systems they got jobs that didn't have
them before so I don't think I'm
eliminating jobs they think I'm
redistributing those jobs a little bit
into technology plays rather than just
straight hook lines but but you know I
think that that the restaurant industry
is being challenged unlike others you
know there's many states where tipped
employees get paid about 220 an hour and
it's an employee tip credit of you know
whatever it is $13 an hour to adjust
their payroll down so these employees
typically make twenty thirty forty
dollars an hour in tips in many of these
places so they make 220 now in payroll
from 220 an hour to $15 is a 600 percent
payroll increase there is no business in
the world that can sustain a 6
hundred percent payroll increase so I'm
trying to protect my industry I'm trying
to protect the people that work in the
industry by creating a stable economic
model so there is no guilt instability
there is no guilt in following you know
economic models that provide prosperity
for those who work for us it isn't my
choice I'd much rather be hiring more
people but it isn't something I have any
guilt about yeah I love the answer I
mean that that's the honest answer and
unfortunately we've got a lot of
business owners these days that would
give you the guilt answer to just sort
of pretend they're doing the right thing
as opposed to actually actually doing
the right thing if somebody if
somebody's watching this right now and
they're young and they always wanted to
get into the biz you know you talked
about a long resume of doing basically
everything what would you recommend I
mean is is the first job just to be a
barback or do you have like a specific
idea and on how they get in on this yeah
you know I think the most important two
jobs or a wide cook in a barback you
learn everything from those two
positions or bartender so you know I'm
of the belief that that you should not
go into this business until you're at
least ten bar and work in a kitchen
those are the two areas where waste
occurs those are the two areas with
theft occurs those are the two hearts of
the of the business if it breaks down
there in either of those places you have
no business the worst thing in the world
in a restaurant industry is to be held
hostage to ignorance I can't tell you
how many friends have had over the years
that have opened restaurants that have
never been in a business before they
hire a chef right they pay Amex amount
of hours a year they're open 60 days the
chef says this is all on me I won equity
or I'm leaving and the guy who owns it
doesn't know how to cook a steak or
doesn't even know one of his own recipes
he's held hostage by his ignorance this
is a challenging business you know think
of a retail store but the t-shirts go
bad after three days how about that
imagine a t-shirt shop that they rot
away after three or four days you know
that there's staff that so we have to
manage production we have to manage
retail management izing manage staff
manage purchasing it's a very difficult
business and you can't do it from a
point of ignorance those are the people
who fail and it's interesting day
because if you look at the statistics
about one of the eight restaurants
succeed for first time operator seven of
eight succeed for the second time Wow
it's a fascinating shift in the
statistics so once you've made those
mistakes the first time they've you're
sort of ready now but without the
experience you're not in a very good
statistical place with the experience
you're in a far better statistical place
what what resources can we send people
to are you still doing seminars on sure
yeah sure we still do seminars you go to
John Taffer calm matter-of-fact we're
working on an industry webinar in the
next couple of weeks so you can go visit
John Taffer calm you know there's great
resources out there for restaurant
people please go to the National
Restaurant Association site they have
wonderful kovat information great
marketing programs and such there's
another organization a nightclub and bar
show a media group which also has great
information on it and then of course you
know we have our TV T which is about 40
hours of training content marketing
promotion that we have that's available
on our website also my point is this you
know when this pandemic started that and
I'd like to sort of be positive here for
a minute Dave you know when this
pandemic started I saw people get
paralyzed they didn't know what to do
they were frozen you know my second book
about excuses which we talked about you
know I realized that at this time great
marketers are gonna bubble to the top
aren't they
we're gonna see some amazing stuff great
promoters are gonna bubble to the top
we're gonna see great activations and
programs and online events and great
operators are getting bubble to the top
we're gonna see incredible things happen
out there so this is a time to mobilize
not paralyze if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlists they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell